six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go next to our caller
from the 7:04 area code caller from 7:04
welcome to the program go ahead hey
David how are you good how are you I'm
good
first this on the side do you watch the
counter-arguments channel no I don't
know what that is okay because you were
recently featured in one of their videos
you weren't the subject necessarily but
their video was on just interview style
and maintaining neutrality with the main
subject of the discussion being Dave
Rubin oh I would love to see that no
I've not I've not seen that and you mean
counter-arguments not contra points
right I know contra points no no no the
counter-argument okay no I haven't seen
it
yeah birdy channel anyhow um yeah I'm
not sure if you talked about on the live
show yet but what do you think of us
pulling out of the United Nations Human
Rights Council uh you know here's the
thing about that I get that there are
problems within the UN and I also agree
that something like Saudi Arabia being
on the Human Rights Council of the UN is
absolutely ludicrous right so I can't
totally disagree with the idea that the
Human Rights Council is a joke because
how could Saudi Arabia be involved with
anything that is Human Rights it doesn't
make any sense public beheadings and
subjugation of women and it's a disaster
at the same time that what the idea of
Trump pulling out of it is problematic
in two ways number one that if we want
to make the Human Rights Council a
better thing than we need good allies on
there and you know you can make the case
that the United States is problematic
for its own reasons but considering that
we've been voices on there to counter
Saudi Arabia the other issue is that
we're also completely in cahoots with
Saudi Arabia so part of the reason we
call that a joke is because Saudi Arabia
is on there but then we also do arms
deals with Saudi Arabia so it's all it's
quite a perplexing conundrum overall oh
yeah but big picture I am NOT for the
United States
being involved in the human rights
account I think we should be involved
and I think we should try to reform it
and I think Trump pulling out of it is
part of its not so much about the
individual decision by Trump to pull out
of the Human Rights Council its pulling
out of the Iran deal pulling out of the
Paris climate Accords pulling out of the
UN UN Human Rights Council it's this
idea that he is sort of retracting the
United States for really no good reason
and it's actually damaging our
relationships with allies all over the
world so I'm against Trump's decision
even though I'm really concerned about
that Human Rights Council yeah it just
sets another precedent for us you know
like abandoning any effort for global
cooperation yeah who would trust us to
do a deal if they see that we'll just
pull out of whatever right I mean it
just it's it's not how you inspire
geopolitical confidence agreed all right
thank you so much for the call very much
appreciate it